[Musik]
machtprobe im britischen unterhaus mit
einem neuen gesetz wollen die no deal
gegner einen exit ohne abkommen
verhindern
aus zwei mach eins in hessen lägen die
konkurrenten sparkasse und volksbank
viele ihrer filialen zusammen blamablen
vorrunden-aus für deutschlands
basketballer bei der wm in china
verliert das team auch gegen außenseiter
dominikanische republik
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg den abend und ein
herzliches willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem dienstag
an meiner seite ist für den sport
norbert lehmann
ein schwimmbagger familie den gegnern
von premierminister berief johnson
bleibt nicht viel zeit wenn sie einen
ungeregelten backseat verhindern wollen
muss es schnell gehen
heute kehrte das britische parlament aus
der sommerpause zurück kommende woche
muss es schon wieder in die von johnson
verordnete zwangspause
also heute direkt zur machtprobe eine
fraktionsübergreifende gruppe will im
parlament ein gesetz auf den weg bringen
das eine no deal dexxit verhindert ein
no no deal gesetz quasi das johnson
zwingt brüssel noch einmal um aufschub
zu bitten falls bis ende oktober keine
exit abkommen gibt johnson allerdings
will den wechselt auf gar keinen fall
verschieben und droht mit neuwahlen
aus london jasin herrlein
exklusiv ist die stimmung vor und im
parlament am ersten tag des großen
showdowns und als sprengmeister fungiert
in den augen dieser demonstranten der
premierminister höchstselbst mit seiner
drohung notfalls ein no deal brad pitt
durchzusetzen dies zu verhindern ist das
ziel seiner gegner im parlament das sind
die oppositionsparteien aber auch
abgeordnete aus den reihen der
konservativen wieder sonst eigentlich
stets besondere ehemalige finanzminister
philip hammond money kollegs fit bin
viele meiner kollegen sind sehr erzürnt
über das was in der letzten woche
geschehen ist und ich denke nun ist die
zeit das nationale interesse über unsere
persönlichen interessen zu stellen
ein konservativer abgeordneter ging
sogar noch einen schritt weiter er hat
die partei verlassen und sitzt nun im
parlament neben der vorsitzenden der
europafreundlichen liberaldemokraten
johnson hat nun keine mehrheit mehr
die opposition scheint gestärkt und
geeint in ihrem vorgehen
jetzt bekamen increasing diese
verantwortungslose regierung hat nur
einen klaren uns aus der eu zu schießen
ohne einen deal
johnsons der blick darauf
alles was die opposition will ist mich
dazu zu zwingen denn brüssel um eine
weitere sinnlose verlängerung zu betteln
dazu wollen die noten gegner heute abend
die kontrolle über die tagesordnung
erlang und dann morgen ein
entsprechendes gesetz zu erlassen und
über all dem schwebt weiterhin die
möglichkeit einer baldigen neuwahl
diana zimmermann ist für uns vor dem
parlament in london wo einiges los ist
diana vor und im parlament wird mit
harten bandagen gekämpft
also hier ist zahlenmäßig nicht
überwältigend dafür umso stimmgewaltiger
im parlament wird mit harten bandagen
mit zuckerbrot und peitsche gekämpft
boris johnson verspricht seinen
parlamentariern heute noch einmal dass
er es schaffen wird der eu einen neuen
besseren deal abzuringen er behauptet
die verhandlungen mit der eu gingen gut
voran
brüssel übrigens negiert das und sagt
überhaupt wird morgen erst mit michelle
waren hier den unterhändlern noch einmal
gesprochen
gleichzeitig droht schon morgen möchte
ja die opposition dieses gesetz
vorschlagen nachdem johnston gezwungen
werden soll eine notbremse zu verhindern
indem er nach brüssel geht und noch
einmal eine verschiebung des austritts
datums beantragt mit der opposition
haben etwa ein dutzend konservative
gesagt werden sie für dieses gesetz
stimmen
johnston hat nun unverhohlen gedroht
diejenigen konservativen die das tun
werden bei den nächsten wahlen nicht
mehr
in wahlkreisen kandidieren dürfen doch
das kann jeder entscheiden
ihnen droht also womöglich schon im
oktober der job verliert trotzdem sind
die rebellen guter hoffnung dass sie
heute abend zu tagesordnung an sich
reißen können und morgen das gesetz
verabschiedete der beiden
schicksalhaften abstimmung findet heute
abend gegen 11 uhr verzeichnet wir sind
gespannt turbulente tage in lohmen
vielen dank der zimmermann
die debatte im londoner unterhaus geht
voraussichtlich noch bis weit in die
nacht sie können direkt dabei sein den
live stream finden sie in unserem online
angebot auf heute.de fünf menschen sind
tot mehr als 13.000 häuser zerstört herr
iken dorian wütet noch immer über den
bahamas seit er am sonntag ankam will
erzieherin nicht von dort weichen
und genau deshalb entfaltet er seine
volle kraft aktuell im norden dann zieh
dorian wohl entlang der us-küste weiter
und könnte noch mehr schäden verursachen
auch wenn er an stärke verloren hat
britta jäger noch ist das ausmaß der
schäden auf den bahamas nicht in vollem
umfang sichtbar
doch klar ist schon jetzt die zerstörung
ist gewaltig nur langsam zieht dorian
richtung norden über die inselgruppe
er bringt heftigen wind und sturmfluten
hinterlässt schwer zerstörte wohngebiete
es ist der schlimmste hurrikan der die
bahamas je heimgesucht hat
die leute versuchen in den häusern so
weit es geht nach oben zu gehen
im moment gibt es wenig was die
rettungsteams tun können weil man sieht
ja der wind ist heftig es ist einfach
schrecklich
der premierminister der bahamas spricht
von krieg der feind ein hurrikan die
bahamas ohne geeignete waffen
sie sind im norden der bahamas mitten in
einer historischen tragödie
wir müssen uns jetzt auf die suche
die rettung der menschen und den
wiederaufbau fokussieren mit der
stärksten kategorie fünf batterien auf
die inseln getroffen nun stufte ihn das
hurrikan zentrum der usa auf kategorie
zwei herunter
zurzeit steckt er über den bahamas fest
wird dann wohl richtung us-ostküste
weiterziehen du sicher ist dein haus du
bleibst drin und wartest dann dass er
kommt je langsamer er durchzieht desto
größer wird die zerstörung sein und
desto mehr sorgen müssen uns machen
die us amerikaner warten und bereiten
sich auf das schlimmste vor
nach deutschland der druck und die
erwartungen sind groß in gut zwei wochen
will die bundesregierung ihr klimaschutz
konzept vorstellen
und die spd hat schon den fortbestand
der koalition infrage gestellt wenn es
keine fortschritte gibt heute nun wurden
die pläne der union konkret andreas
weise berichtet klimawerkstatt der union
in berlin vorschläge werden eingebracht
und diskutiert am nachmittag plädiert
die cdu chefin dafür endlich loszulegen
auf der suche nach der perfekten lösung
und nach dem immer noch besseren und
immer noch mehr dürfen wir uns nicht
davon abhalten lassen endlich den ersten
schritt zu gehen denn meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren wir haben kein
erkenntnisproblem wir haben noch nicht
einmal ein ideen problem wir haben ein
umsetzungsproblem
cdu und csu haben sich auf einige
kernpunkte geeinigt unter anderem auf
eine ausweitung des co2 emissionshandels
auf verkehr und gebäude ebenso auf einen
ausbau des öffentlichen nahverkehrs und
eine erhöhung der pendlerpauschale mehr
klimaschutz jahr aber keine
mehrbelastung für die bürger das mantra
der union gegen billig flugtickets
allerdings wollen beide entschlossen
vorgehen 9 euro ist für mich kein
akzeptabler flugpreis weil er
weder wirtschaftlich ist noch ökologisch
sinnvoll einigkeit in vielen dingen doch
die csu hat auch ein paar extra ideen
unter anderem will sie deutlich vor 2038
raus aus der braunkohle die klimapläne
der union für die grünen kommen sie
reichlich spät seit 14 jahren unterhält
sich die cdu csu über den klimaschutz
und gehandelt hat sie nie so dass es
wirklich was geholfen hat am 20
september berät dann die große koalition
im klima kabinett wie ihre
gesamtstrategie aussehen soll
in nordhessen sind bei wartungsarbeiten
an einer sendeanlage drei menschen ums
leben gekommen
sie stürzten in einer gondel 50 meter in
die tiefe
unglücksursache könnten probleme mit der
seilwinde gewesen sein
die anlage gehört dem hessischen
rundfunk eine firma sollte sie warten
und nun zu einem prozess der
weitreichende folgen für politiker und
beamte in deutschland haben könnte der
europäische gerichtshof entscheidet
darüber ob in bestimmten fällen
zwangshaft gegen politiker verhängt
werden kann
konkreter der die deutsche umwelthilfe
diese maßnahme beantragt weil die
bayerische landesregierung ein
gerichtsurteil über mögliche fahrverbote
nicht umgesetzt hatte joachim pohl hat
die details sie könnte es theoretisch
treffen bayerns umweltminister glaube
und sogar seinen regierungschef söder
können sie hinter gitter gebracht werden
weil sie nicht gehandelt haben sprich im
luftreinhalteplan für münchen keine
fahrverbote vorsah
obwohl ein gericht das angeordnet hatte
und sogar schon ein zwangsgeld verhängt
wurde
zahlen musste damals das bayerische
umweltministerium zahlungsempfänger war
das bayerische innenministerium heißt
der freistaat zahlt an sich selbst die
deutsche umwelthilfe will das nicht
hinnehmen will mehr druck auf die
politik wir waren ziemlich fassungslos
dass es trotz mehrmaliger androhung und
verhängung von zwangsgeldern nicht
gelungen ist den bayerischen staat dazu
zu bringen richtung gesetz zu beachten
deswegen blieb und sich anderes übrig
als beugehaft gegenüber dem
ministerpräsidenten zu beantragen
dicke luft auf münchens straßen die
stickoxid konzentration liegt seit
jahren
teilweise über den erlaubten grenzwerten
die deutsche umwelthilfe klagte auf
zwangshaft für staatsdiener als letzter
stopp mit bayerns verwaltungsgerichtshof
hat den eugh in luxemburg um rechtliche
bewertungen die politik waren
vermutlichen folgen
das hat eine weitreichende folge für
nahezu die gesamte deutsche politik für
alle beamten wenn dies möglich wäre
das wird nämlich dazu dass sie dann
erleben werden dass ein großteil der
beamten nie mehr irgendeine entscheidung
treffen wird aber selbst wenn der ogh in
einigen monaten zu einer zwangshaft für
staatsdiener grundsätzlich ja sagt
keiner würde gleich hinter gitter
wandern die justiz in bayern müsste da
noch endgültig urteilen all das wird
dauern
in italien hängt die regierungsbildung
am seidenen faden die basis der
populistischen fünf sterne bewegung hat
über eine koalition mit den
sozialdemokraten abgestimmt
regierungschef konnte rief deren
parteimitglieder per videobotschaft dazu
auf das neue bündnis unter seiner
führung anzunehmen
bis 18 uhr konnten die fünf stammende
mitglieder online abstimmen die alte
koalition mit der rechten lega war auf
betreiben von innenminister sei wie im
august zerbrochen
das abstimmungsergebnis wird noch am
abend erwartet noch ist es nicht da wir
fragen nach bei annette hilsenbeck in
rom alles andere als ein jahr der fünf
sterne basis wäre ja wohl ein ende der
regierungsbildung in italien
was ist richtig und deswegen hat die
parteispitze der fünf sterne regierung
auch die frage auf die die mitglieder
beantworten mit ja oder nein antworten
sollten so formuliert möglichst viele
fünf sterne mitglieder dazu zu bewegen
einer koalition zuzustimmen sind sie
denn bereit das die fünf sterne und die
pd gemeinsam eine koalition bilden unter
dem jetzigen regierungschef dieser
bekannte und das ist genau der punkt
dieser bekommt daher selber kein
mitglied der fünf sterne ist aber ihnen
nahesteht ist einfach ungemein beliebt
er war ja als premierminister bisher
galt er als mittler aber vielleicht
gerade deswegen mögen ihn die italiener
ist sogar zum teil beliebter als matteo
salvini
natürlich hoffen jetzt die fünf sterne
dass dieser geschickte schachzug auch
tatsächlich wirkt seit einer halben
stunde sollte es bereits eine
pressekonferenz geben die ist noch nicht
die hat noch nicht angefangen da wollte
luigi di maio eigentlich die ergebnisse
vorstellen
wenn konnte es gelingt tatsächlich die
fünf sterne hinter sich zu bringen
dann wäre eine wichtige hürde geschafft
und könnte bald zum staatspräsidenten
materieller gehen sein
regierungsprogramm seine regierungsliste
abgeben und vielleicht schon ende der
woche die vertrauensfrage im parlament
stellen und dann hätte italien
tatsächlich bald eine neue regierung
wir halten sie auf dem laufenden vielen
dank erstmal nach oben annette
hilsenbeck nach kalifornien bei einem
bei dem brand auf einem ausflugsschiff
vor der küste sind offenbar alle
urlauber an bord ums leben gekommen
20 leichen wurden geborgen für 14
vermisste besteht kaum noch hoffnung
das feuer hatte die tauch urlauber im
schlaf überrascht nur die besatzung die
sich auf dem oberdeck aufhielt überlebte
compal awp berichtet mayday mayday
mayday
ich kann nicht atmen dieser notruf bei
der küstenwache lässt bereits schlimmes
erahnen
das feuer bricht mitten in der nacht aus
von den 39 menschen an bord schlafen die
meisten unter deck das etwa 23 meter
lange boot wird für sie zur tödlichen
falle
das ist wahrscheinlich das schlimmste
szenario das man sich vorstellen kann
man hat ein schiff auf hoher see mitten
in der nacht gegen 3 uhr 30 am morgen
feuer ist ein übel für jedes schiff die
konzeption war vor der kalifornischen
küste unterwegs in der nähe der insel
santa cruz zu einem taucher ausflug dann
die tragödie
als die einsatzkräfte eintreffen ist
nichts mehr zu retten das boot sinkt
später samt insassen nur fünf
besatzungsmitglieder konnten sich retten
hoffnung auf weitere überlebende gibt es
kaum noch
nun beginnt die suche nach der ursache
des feuers dabei interessiert die
ermittler auch warum die crew mitglieder
sich selbst aber keinen der passagiere
retten konnten
anita lasker wallfisch hat die gräuel
der konzentrationslager überlebt und
berichtet auch als 94 jährige weiter
beeindruckend vom antisemitismus der
nazizeit
heute bekam sie den mit 30.000 euro
dotierten deutschen nationalpreis
bundespräsident steinmeier würdigte ihr
bemühen um verständigung und ihr
eintreten gegen judenhass lasker
wallfisch überlebte die
vernichtungslager auschwitz und bergen
belsen weil sie mitglied im frauen- und
fester war seit 1994 spricht sie mit
schülern in deutschland über diese zeit
fast jeder bank oder sparkassen kunde
bekommt es zu spüren aus kostengründen
gibt es immer weniger filialen 1995
waren es bundesweit noch rund 72.000
dann sinkt die zahl 2018 sind es nur
noch knapp 28.000 zweigstellen fast zwei
drittel weniger
die frankfurter volksbank und die taunus
sparkasse betreten jetzt neuland die
konkurrenten teilen sich künftig
filialen wie das funktionieren soll
zeigt in peking
so sollen die neuen filialen aussehen
die sich die taunus sparkasse und die
frankfurter volksbank künftig teilen
wollen finanz punkt werden sie heißen
an tagen mit blauem licht sind die
mitarbeiter der volksbank vor ort
leuchtet das rote licht beraten
angestellte der sparkasse ihre kunden
geschäftsstellen gehören wie
online-banking und apps zu einer
modernen bank aber keiner hat gesagt
dass man die exklusiv alleine betreiben
muss wir haben so ein modell gefunden
wie wir geschäftsstellen sichern
investieren und gleichzeitig auch noch
kosten sparen
in einem so großen umfang hat es das
noch nicht gegeben
aus rund 50 filialen im taunus werden 26
bereits in diesem jahr sollen die ersten
geschäftsstellen eröffnet werden
bei kunden geteiltes echo
naja ich ein bisschen merkwürdig ich sag
mal ich mach sowieso mehr online banking
jetzt schon
ich finde es wichtig dass filialen noch
erhalten bleiben weil der für ältere
leute
für experten ist die neue zusammenarbeit
von konkurrenten nachvollziehbar
die filiale sind nach wie vor teuer dass
der folgerichtige schritt ist weniger
filialen oder eben dieser unorthodoxe
schritt zu filialen zusammenlegen
für die kunden weniger flexibilität für
die bank aber die möglichkeit an diesen
tagen dann für den vollen service die
volle beratung anzubieten
entlassungen soll es trotz der
gemeinsamen filialen nicht geben
schellberg auch in anderen regionen in
deutschland ist ein solches modell
denkbar aber jetzt erstmal zu sparen sie
wieder ein souveräner sieg der deutschen
fußball frauen kann man wohl sagen dass
von bundestrainerin martina
voss-tecklenburg gestern angekündigte
harte stück arbeit gegen den
vermeintlich starken em gegner in der
qualifikation ukraine entpuppte sich
dann heute doch eher als ein
spielerischer spaziergang 18 0 der
endstand
dominant und sehr präsent die deutsche
elf kleine schwächen in defensive und
chancenverwertung fallen nicht ins
gewicht
sara däbritz stellt nach vier minuten
die weichen
dina magull und felicitas rauch sorgen
zur pause für einen 13 0 für die
mannschaft von martina voss-tecklenburg
in der zweiten halbzeit dann die tour
premiere der 17 jahre alte
abwehrspielerin li na oberdorf und vier
weitere treffer in der schlussphase der
brits dabei mit ihren toren zwei und
drei
als letzter höhepunkt leonie meyers 8 zu
0 gegen einen biederen gegner
die fußballfrauen haben also einen em
quali gegner hinter sich die herren
dagegen haben einen vor sich und zwar
einen richtig starken die niederlande am
freitag in hamburg heute erstes training
mit rückkehrer joachim löw nach einem
sportunfall wieder dienstfähig der
bundestrainer konnte heute beim training
im stadion des fc st pauli mit dem
kompletten kader trainieren auch nach
zuletzt drei siegen nacheinander bleiben
sie angemessen vorsichtig wir spielen zu
hause wir haben ein gutes
selbstbewusstsein aber wissen natürlich
auch dass es ein ganz schwieriges spiel
wird und wir wissen natürlich auch dass
wir ein paar verletzte haben die dem
trainer als alternative fehlen nach dem
ausfall von son er wird wohl werner in
die startelf rücken und mit neuling luca
waldschmidt steht eine weitere
alternative im angriff bereit
kevin krawietz und andreas mies haben
bei den us open als einzige deutsche
spieler das viertelfinale erreicht durch
den zweisatz sieg über das doppel
leonardo mayer und joao sousa
zuvor waren in den einzel achtelfinals
julia goerges und alexanders wäre
ausgeschieden und aus der traum von
einer wm medaille für die deutsche
basketball-nationalmannschaft nach der
blamablen niederlage gegen die
dominikanische republik
die enttäuschung ist riesig deutschlands
basketballer verpassen wie schon gegen
frankreich den anfang der partie 0 zu 8
gegen den außenseiter das vorab so stark
eingeschätzte deutsche team durchgängig
mit schlechter trefferquote präsenz und
willen zeigt nur der gegner 52 zu 55
steht es im dritten viertel
am ende heißt es 68 zu 70 gegen die
dominikanische republik nach der zweiten
wm niederlage ist für deutschland
maximal noch rang 17 möglich und
obendrein die qualifikation für olympia
in gefahr
das war es von mir dankeschön fürs
wetter wird sonnig und warm später
ziehen im nordwesten schauer auf die
details hat gleich gunther tiersch man
jetzt als longa begrüßt sie um viertel
vor zehn im heute schon mal danke für
ihr interesse haben wir noch einen
unbeschwerten abend und wenn sie mögen
wir sind wieder da auch wieder hin
[Musik]
und am liebe zuschauer für die meisten
von ihnen würde es morgen sonnig und
warm allerdings schon regen unterwegs
der liegt zurzeit über großbritannien
wie diesen fronten system das uns dann
morgen im norden und westen erreicht mit
ersten regenschauern und dahinter ab
donnerstag wird es von nordwesten eben
deutlich kühler werden
ja heute nacht ist alles ruhig es gibt
ein paar schauer noch vereinzelt an der
nord und ostseeküste sonst klart es auf
oder wir haben ein paar nebelfelder es
wird frisch im süden morgen früh sind
dort nur vier bis neun grad an den
küsten bleibt es deutlich milder und
tagsüber scheint erst einmal die sonne
aber schon am vormittag werden die
wolken hier im norden dichter und ab
mittag fängt an zu regnen erste schauer
von der nordsee bis zum niederrhein
nachmittags dann nur langsam kommen sie
voran nach osten so lübecker bucht
niedersachsen bis zur eifel ansonsten
bleibt es eben trocken und auch sonnig
und der wind ist zum teil stürmisch vor
allen dingen an der nordsee aus
südwesten die temperaturen dann dort so
von der ostsee bis zum niederrhein 18
bis 22 grad
meist wird sehr warm 24 bis 29 grad das
war s dann es wird kühler wechselhafter
in den nächsten tagen ist beginnt am
donnerstag und am samstag haben wir noch
so 14 bis 19 grad ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut